양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고 IBM Quantum 교육 기술 총괄이에요.
이번이 시리즈의 13번째 강의이고, 양자 오류에 관한 네 번째이자 마지막 단원의 첫 번째 강의예요.
정정이죠. Quantum Computing은 효율적인 고전 알고리즘이 알려지지 않은 계산 작업에 대해 효율적인 해결책을 가능하게 할 잠재력을 갖고 있어요.
그런데 아마 존재하지 않을 수도 있죠. 하지만 우리가 언젠가 가능하길 바라는 대규모 양자 계산을 구현하려면 극복해야 할 매우 중요한 과제들이 있어요.
그게 실현되려면 반드시 넘어야 할 벽들이 있는 거죠. 핵심 문제는 양자 정보가 엄청나게 취약하다는 거예요. 말 그대로 그냥 바라보기만 해도
망가질 수 있어요. 그래서 양자 컴퓨터가 제대로 작동하려면 자신이 저장하는 양자 정보를
주변 환경으로부터 극도로 차단해야 해요. 동시에 양자 컴퓨터 자체는 우리에게
이 양자 정보에 대한 매우 정밀한 제어를 제공해야 해요. 여기에는 올바른 초기화, 정확하고 신뢰할 수 있는
유니터리 연산, 그리고 당연히 측정을 수행할 수 있는 능력이 포함돼요. 그래야 실제로 계산 결과를 얻을 수 있죠.
계산 결과를 얻을 수 있어요. 이 요구 사항들 사이에는 분명히 긴장감이 있고, Quantum Computing 초창기에는 양자 정보의 취약성 때문에 어떤 사람들은
계산 결과를 얻을 수 있어요. 이 요구 사항들 사이에는 분명 긴장감이 있고, Quantum Computing 초창기에는 양자 정보의 취약성이
부정확성과 환경 노이즈 모두에 대한 취약성 때문에 결국 Quantum Computing을 불가능하게 만들 거라고 생각한 사람들도 있었어요. 오늘날에는 정확하고 신뢰할 수 있는
대규모 양자 컴퓨터를 만드는 것이 엄청난 도전이라는 데 거의 의심의 여지가 없어요. 하지만 우리에게는 이 노력에서 도움이 되는 핵심 도구가 있어요.
그 도구는 언젠가 대규모 Quantum Computing이 현실이 될 것이라고 이 분야에 정통한 대부분의 사람들을 낙관하게 만들어요. 그 도구는 바로 양자 오류
정정이에요. 다음 네 강의에서는 Quantum 오류 정정에 대해 기초에 초점을 맞춰 논의할 거예요.
이번 강의에서는 Quantum 오류 정정을 처음으로 살펴볼 건데, 최초로 발견된 양자 오류 정정 코드 중 하나인
9 qubit Shore 코드도 포함돼요. 또한 Quantum 오류 정정의 또 다른 기본 개념도 논의할 거예요.
바로 오류의 이산화라고 알려진 개념이에요. 단원의 이후 강의에서는 더 정교하고 궁극적으로 더 나은
Quantum 오류 정정 코드 구성을 살펴보고, 자체적으로 완벽하지 않고 오류가 발생하기 쉬운 계산 구성 요소를 사용하는 인코딩된 양자 정보에 대한 양자 계산 문제도 논의할 거예요.
계산 구성 요소를 사용하는 인코딩된 양자 정보에 대한 양자 계산 문제도 논의할 거예요. 강의의 간략한 개요를 알려드릴게요.
아마도 가장 단순하고 기본적인 유형의 고전 오류 정정 코드인 고전 반복 코드에 대한 논의로 시작할 거예요.
고전 오류 정정 코드에 대한 논의로 시작할 거예요. 고전 반복 코드는 고전적인
코딩 이론 기준으로는 특별히 좋은 코드가 아니에요. 적어도 단독으로는요. 하지만 괜찮아요. 여기서는 단순성을 추구하는 거니까요.
특히 우리는 상상할 수 있는 가장 단순한 고전 오류 정정 코드를 살펴볼 건데, 그걸 간단한 예시의 기초로 사용할 거예요.
그 예시는 바로 간단한 Quantum 오류 정정 코드예요. 자세히 논의할 그 예시는 9 qubit Shore 코드예요.
자세히 논의할 9 qubit Shore 코드가 그 예시예요. 코드 자체에 대한 설명과 함께
이 코드를 사용해 qubit를 인코딩하는 절차, 인코딩된 qubit의 오류 감지,
오류 정정도 포함돼요. 강의의 세 번째 부분에서는 오류의 이산화에 대해 논의할 건데, 이는 우리가
원칙적으로 연속적인 가능성을 형성하는 qubit의 임의적인 오류를 이산적인 용어로 생각할 수 있게 해줘요. 본질적으로 오류를
소위 비트 플립과 위상 플립으로 줄여주는 거죠. Quantum 오류 정정의 기술적인 세부 사항으로 들어가기 전에
잠깐 Quantum 오류 정정의 필요성과 함께 고전 오류 정정의 필요성도 생각해보는 게 좋을 것 같아요.
강의 시작에서 제가 말했듯이 양자 컴퓨터는 오류에 매우 취약한데, 이는
양자 정보의 취약성 때문이에요. 특히 환경, 즉
나머지 세계와의 원치 않는 상호작용이 양자 정보를 방해할 수 있어요. 이런 원치 않는 상호작용은 정보가
환경으로 새어 나가는 디코히어런스를 일으킬 수 있고, 양자 컴퓨터에 저장된 정보가 점점 더
고전적으로 행동하게 만들어요. 또한 양자 연산은 제한된
정확도로만 수행될 수 있다는 점을 인식하는 것도 매우 중요해요. 예를 들어 우리는 qubit에 특정 Quantum gate를 수행하고 싶을 수 있는데, 물리적 장치는
절대 완벽하지 않기 때문에 실제로 구현하는 건 그 gate의 근사치에 불과할 수 있어요. 단일 gate에서는 큰 문제가 아닐 수 있지만
우리의 의도가 수천 또는 수백만 개의 quantum gate를 수행하는 거라면, 이런 작은 부정확성들이
쌓이기 시작할 거예요. 계산이 끝나면 우리가
예상했던 것과 매우 다른 상태가 될 수 있어요. 이건 꽤 다른 오류 원인이지만 분명히 무시할 수 없는 것이에요.
사람들은 거의 한 세기 동안 고전 오류 정정 코드를 연구해 왔고, 이 코드들은 정보 전송 및 저장을 포함한 많은 응용 프로그램을 갖고 있어요.
하지만 고전 컴퓨팅 구성 요소가 매우 신뢰할 수 있기 때문에 우리는 실제로 고전 컴퓨터를 만드는 데 오류 정정이 필요하지 않아요.
신뢰할 수 있는 대규모 양자 컴퓨터를 만드는 데도 오류 정정이 실제로 필요하지 않을 수도 있어요. 예를 들어 위상 Quantum Computing의 핵심 아이디어는
노이즈에 대해 본질적으로 보호되는 강력한 Quantum 시스템을 구축할 수 있을 거라는 것인데,
시스템의 위상적 특성 때문에 그럴 수 있다는 거예요. 하지만 이게 가능할지 모르고, 대규모 Quantum Computing에는
오류 정정이 어떤 형태로든 아마 필수적일 거라고 꽤 널리 믿어지고 있어요. 이제 우리는 고전
반복 코드에 대해 논의할 건데, 이건 곧 보게 될 첫 번째 Quantum 오류 정정 코드인 9 qubit Shore 코드의 기초를 형성해요.
반복 코드는 오류 정정 코드의 극히 기본적인 예시예요.
반복 코드예요. 핵심 아이디어는 각 비트를 여러 번 반복함으로써 오류로부터 비트를 보호할 수 있다는 거예요. 특히
3비트 반복 코드를 살펴볼게요. 여기서 우리는 비트를 단순히 세 번 반복함으로써 하나의 비트를 세 개로 인코딩해요.
3비트 반복 코드를 살펴볼게요. 비트를 단순히 세 번 반복함으로써 하나의 비트를 세 개로 인코딩하는 거예요.
0은 000으로 인코딩되고 1은 111로 인코딩돼요. 물론 아무 문제가 없으면
두 가지 가능성을 쉽게 구별할 수 있어요. 하지만 오류가 있어서 비트 중 하나가 뒤집혔다면, 예를 들어
0이 1로 바뀌거나 1이 0으로 바뀐다면, 두 이진 값 중 어느 것이 두 번 나타나는지를 보면 원래 비트가 뭐였는지 알 수 있어요.
동등하게, 다수결 값을 계산해서 디코딩할 수 있어요.
즉 가장 자주 나타나는 이진 값을 찾는 거예요. 비트 플립 오류가 최대 하나라면
디코딩이 정확할 거라는 건 어렵지 않게 알 수 있어요. 물론 두 비트가 뒤집히거나
세 비트 모두 뒤집히면 작동하지 않고 디코딩할 때 잘못된 값을 얻게 돼요. 그건 일반적인 속성이에요.
모든 오류 정정 코드가 갖는 속성이죠. 일부 오류는 정정할 수 있지만 모든 오류를 정정할 수는 없어요. 결국 이건
정확성을 보장하는 것이 아니라 오류 가능성을 줄이는 것에 관한 거예요. 일반적으로 그건